all right and we're back once again for
another movie review this one is kind of
an obscure one this is a good flick it
is actually yes and it's funny because
you remembered it from when you were a
kid you remember seeing it you told me
about it I had never seen it I'd never
heard of it I watched it a million times
on cable and it's weird I missed it and
I used to watch movies on cable with
that it's a weird story because it kind
of scared the [ __ ] out of me in a way it
had elements of slasher films it's a
very weird but it also had like elements
of adventure
it's a little bit like elements of
morality tale yeah all happening at once
it's well-written movie and I got well
acted yeah although I have to say that
not not a lot of people share that
opinion I guess but here okay so here's
the thing here's the thing the weird
thing about this movie which is called
the island if we didn't mention it yeah
it came out when 1980 I want to say yeah
okay so the story of the movie was
actually based on a novel by Peter
Benchley obviously you're right jaws and
the deep yeah and Peter Benchley also
wrote the screenplay for this now at
this point like I said they'd already
made jaws which was a huge blockbuster
they made the deep which also made a lot
of money even though I don't think
anybody remembers that nowadays except
for maybe Jacqueline Bisset and her
makini or whatever I don't even remember
what that [ __ ] was about I saw and think
about a moray eel or something woman
something like some lotion he I don't
know yeah but yes so those two were like
huge hits so it was kind of like I guess
they kind of felt like Peter Benchley
we're making a movie out of Peter
Benchley book cha-ching okay well that
didn't happen and the thing about the
island is that it costs more money to
make than jaws and the deep combined
yeah and yet it was a total and utter
flop I don't know why I think I was just
trying to do it timing I like deep but I
liked it too but it's like I think it's
aged very well I don't really understand
why it I think this movie has aged very
well this is better than most of the
crap that's coming out of Hollywood I
actually kind of
I didn't expect to but I actually kind
of liked it and I don't know it's just
it's weird because like it's like I said
at the time there's not really a lot of
reviews on it or anything like that
but evidently when it came out it was
nominated for the first you know they do
the Golden Raspberry Awards for like the
worst movie of the year whatever I guess
1980 or 1981 was there like inaugural
and golden raspberry and this was
nominated for worst actor and worst
movie worst director I don't know why
yeah it's not bad at all oh it was also
directed by the same guy the guy that
directed it
Michael Ritchie he's dead now but um he
did the Bad News Bears yeah he did the
Flesch movies with Chevy Chase
he later did the golden child variety
Murphy which I know a lot of people [ __ ]
on that baby but I kind of liked it well
lay it out lay it out for the people so
they know what the island is kind of a
box okay so the island basically Michael
Caine is in it David Warner is also in
it and I [ __ ] love David Warren don't
watch any things like he's a neutron
yeah he's in a shitload of semester
control he was in time after time which
we really have to do a breakdown yeah
okay wait someone you get to see how
skinny this do this oh my god his arms
Alexa I feel like he wasn't that skinny
in time after time though and that only
came out like a year before man he's
maybe he got sick or something smaller
than like a small girl Celie that was
like some anorexia yeah I went on there
but anyway okay so Michael Caine is like
the star of the movie and he's like he
plays a guy named Blair Maynard who
races Michael [ __ ] Kane well yeah
yeah I like Mike okay I know even though
he kind of like he's kind of like this
is in the middle of his paycheck era
where he's just showing off for a
paycheck
that's a funny disgusting Satie's
paycheck kind of like so British about
the guy he in most of time he's like a
dick he plays the dudes is just an
[ __ ] but you like him for some reason
yeah he's like a lovable yeah you like
you like your [ __ ] dick dude he's a
lovable [ __ ] yeah he plays really
good lovable bastards right and that
hair yeah it's like a brillo pad it is I
think the little curly I don't know what
that's about
yes looks at [ __ ] yes acting is just
looking at some [ __ ] huh
right I never realized that you got to
grow up in the 70s and 80s that's it's
understand the dynamic that is like okay
Michael [ __ ] Kane so Michael [ __ ]
Kane isn't this movie he plays a
character named Blair Maynard yeah and
he is like a hotshot magazine writer or
something like that yeah now he is super
fascinated by this story of like all
these boats have been disappearing yes I
mean a triangle type of thing like all
these people have been disappearing all
these boats have been disappearing he
wants to go check it out and of course
the magazine editors like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
nobody there's but finally he's like oh
please please please and he's a-- okay
so he lets him go now a complication
arises when
Maynard's bratty son Justin you know I
guess he's like 13 yeah 12 I think 12
says they don't do some like that and it
turns out he got dumped on Maynard yeah
the mama didn't want him the MA yeah
like the motion why I am just that she
sent him out - yeah like the mom has a
new boyfriend and I go somewhere and so
like unexpectedly he gets this kid
dumped on him yeah so he's like well I
have to go down to Miami or wherever the
[ __ ] he's going to investigate this
Bermuda Triangle yeah the boat
disappearances so why don't you come
with me it'll be an adventure and we're
going to Florida so I'll take you to
Disney World or whatever right this kid
is like a total douchebag
yes is that yeah he's a total deny my
dick and I would have left him
yeah and I'll take him to Disney World
they talked about Orlando Florida which
that's where we live yeah and they
showed Orlando back in 1980 or 81 yeah
and it looked awesome back then - for
some reason they make they make it seem
they make it sound like Miami and
Orlando Orlando are close they are not
close really not yeah and yeah if you
don't know I mean Florida is very long
or like a penis
and like you know what I mean and so and
I see this a lot in movies especially
people have never been here Orlando and
Miami are not close together not at all
it's like well what is it like a
three-hour drive no more four hours
because I think I used to live in
Daytona Beach which is about an hour
north of
here and we'll north-east kind of and it
took five hours to drive from there to
my so it's about a four hour drive yeah
and if the traffic's good you can make
it about yeah but you know other than
that so it's far apart so he basically
goes down to miami and he kind of be
rents a boat right well they have to
take an airplane to get to 100 that's
right i forgot about that part yeah they
had to take an air and in there on this
like really crappy cargo plane there and
the pilots alway the pilots coolest [ __ ]
you I really like these are my favorite
there's some kind of war veteran he's
burned up on one side of his head he
does a bunch of he's like [ __ ] I
don't really know how to land a plane
anything I was flying by the seat of his
pants yeah before they left he actually
bought a gun for his son a little twenty
two little colt woodsman twenty two type
pistol you know the guy that sold on the
pistol this little sporting pistol guy
sold the pistol kind of got the idea
that maybe Michael Caine was anti-gun or
something you know with his British
accent but Michael Caine drops it out
there and he was a Korea War veteran
alright Korean veteran which saw by well
handy that'll come in handy later my
ears kind of popped up cuz you're not
served in I served in Korea for a year
you know on that DMZ that's hard service
even in peacetime yeah so you know if
you're in those infantry and it's only a
badass against about Korea some of my
audience members will attest to that
alright so it's kind of funny the movie
starts off you kind of think that this
Michael Caine guy that he's playing
Blair Maynard you know you kind of think
that maybe he's kind of a wussy but no
not really
oh Jenny continued well and the thing
that happens here there's like a dynamic
kind of setup between Michael Caine and
the kid are like estranged cuz I guess
the kid goes to private school he's
gonna live with he doesn't know his dad
to he doesn't really know his dad too
well and he's kind of a brat yeah his
dad really doesn't really care too much
about me he cares about him you know but
he yeah there's been a whole lot of time
when right he hasn't spent a whole lot
of time with him it's it wasn't a case
where when he found out the kid got
dumped on and he was like [ __ ] me like
that he's just like oh well you can come
along with me it'll be fine blah blah
blah yeah so you know so they fly down
to the
[ __ ] little piece-of-shit Islanders
yeah airplane crash airplane crashes I
mean they get out but obviously or the
movie would be over yeah but um they
meet our anthropologist down there
British anthropologist wasn't an
anthropologist or something like yeah
something like that or a philosopher I
can't remember
he was he was waxing philosophical
through the his whole scene yeah but I
kind of forgot who he was you find you
see more of him later yeah that was the
profession was he kind of some kind of
anthropologist and repository type who
was being into pria philosophy dr.
Brazil his nameis so they end up running
a boat from the anthropologist it's kind
of tough a guy they're gonna go fishing
because they're gonna do some father-son
bonding [ __ ] I guess so you know that's
cool even though the kids still pissed
about Disney well now it should be noted
that before like all this [ __ ] happens
at the very beginning of the movie you
actually see a few shots and this is
what this is what we were saying what it
seemed yes scare me when I was a kid
well because it has it's really weird
because it's like an action-adventure
type of movie but it also has like
slasher movie kind of it's watched
something on a Friday 13 yeah because
like at the very beginning you see like
these people on boats like they're
fishing and [ __ ] like that and then like
these shadowy people like climb on the
boats at like one guy gets is like
[ __ ] skull cleaved with an accident
yeah like in a total like Friday the
Thursday
a little love yacht gets taken over by
some shadowy figures and they kill the
dad and an eight they garrote the mother
and they steal the little
thirteen-year-old girl yeah they're kind
of like when they show the guys they
look you can't really seems like a
covered in oil and grease yeah you know
they have like flaming torches and
things like that
yeah primitive weapons it's pretty cool
so yeah so you you've seen like little
hints at the beginning like why these
boats are disappearing and stuff like
that but of course Michael Caine doesn't
know any of this right when he goes down
there so him and his son like right a
boat oh we're gonna go out fishing and
the kid gets excited cuz he catches a
barracuda or whatever so then they see a
little girl then she needs help she's in
the water yes
lifeboat or whatever yeah her but her
little life boats capsized and she's out
there calling for help bobbing up and
down so they go over there yeah they
take the boat over there and help her
out and that thing was an ambush it was
a trap yeah it turns out that this
little girl was one of was the little
girl that they kidnapped from one of the
boats earlier yeah now we find out when
Michael Caine and the kid like wake up
because they get knocked out or knocked
out by now Michael Caine does shoot one
of the guys yes she's nosy man he kills
the guy with that pistol but they still
get taken so they wake up and they're
tied up to a pole or whatever and
there's all these [ __ ] people yeah
and they're bizarre and they're weird
you can barely understand what they're
saying it's some kind of weird archaic
mixture of French and English yeah it's
like a weird Leishman kind of mishmash
to language and it's like archaic
English yeah French
yeah and they're reading from this big
book and they're passing judgment and
talking about stuff you don't know what
they're talking about yeah and they're
they look like something kind of out of
Mad Max the real skinny kind of filthy
mixture of a bunch of kind of clothing
and some of the stuff that the guys are
wearing or like old fashioned stuff from
like 1700 yeah like old frock coats the
Bronco things like that yeah and then
okay it comes to pass like this woman
comes out of a hut and she's all like
caked in mud
yeah they got they got Blair Maynard and
his son tied up there kind of like
crucifixion style yeah I mean and
they're being judged for crimes that
they committed yeah you know cuz Blair
killed that guy yeah on this yeah it
turns out that that guy was the mud
woman's husband yeah this woman comes
out she's like covered in this filthy
looking mud and she spits in his face
and she's speaking and kind of broken
English and yeah it turns out she's
pissed because she killed that Blair
killed her husband yeah so okay turns
out that this little secluded island
that the Maynard and his son have been
taken to is populated entirely by
pirates
yeah not [ __ ] pirate ship are these
are real these are
descendants of like real actual like
17th century pirate's yeah and they have
lived they have a population on this
island and they have had pretty much no
contact the outside world other than
stealing [ __ ] from people's oh yeah
that's what they do they go that's why
so many boats have been disappearing
because every time a boat goes by
they're like hey boat and they go out
there and they kill all the people on
board they say bring your stuff and they
take all their stuff so they have been
doing this for 300 years yeah and they
don't look too healthy no turns out
they're pretty badly inbred
yeah well as as it would be as it would
be if they didn't have enough women they
when they when you're watching the movie
I'd probably estimate that there were
maybe about five women but they mostly
just show the one the mud woman yeah but
I forgot what her name was
does she even have a name I'm not sure
they even really mentioned her name okay
I'm gonna look on the Wikipedia page
does the Wikipedia page Beth yeah I
might have been Beth I guess that was
her name did they ever call him that I
don't think I may earlier that older I
don't think they call her older woman
yeah
Chrissy well at first I thought she was
the only woman now it turns out that
she's the only viable woman yes she's
still the only one that can have
children that aren't [ __ ] up right
because and only sometimes cuz evidently
the man that made her killed had knocked
her up and she had the baby and it was
all [ __ ] up right died so now okay and
now is where it gets weird yeah because
now that they're on the island with all
these pirates and stuff like that now
initially they're gonna kill Blair and
keep Justin because they need new kids
they need new blood blah blah blah and
they're just gonna train the kid to be
one of them but then they kind of have
no David Warner is like he plays a guy
named John David and he's like the head
of the Pirates like I said super skinny
I don't know what happened to poor David
Warner in between time after time and
this but jump may be easy but he looks
like alarmingly skinny yeah so they kind
of have it back in forest and it turns
out that what they're gonna do is
they're gonna let Michael Caine be the
mud woman's pet and he has to get her
pregnant yeah
so she like what she like puts it
[ __ ] metal collar around and like
leaves and
around by a chain yeah and like you know
essentially like makes him have sex with
her whenever yeah she's very forthright
yes real skinny and scrawny looking yeah
yeah so you can tell she's like falling
in love with him too though as the thing
is yeah she does kind of like developing
I was trying to escape and she keeps
getting blamed for it but that's kind of
getting ahead of the story yeah but you
know turns out that you that what's
happening is is that the new captain of
the ship he's played by David Warner he
basically runs the crew based upon this
book that was left to him by the
original pirate captain I can't recall
his name yeah I don't remember it was
only mentioned once and it's really not
a big factor but evidently and the way
they talk is so it's so hard to
understand what they're saying
I'd have to watch see it a couple couple
extra times they were left a book by the
original cap on how to manage the crew
who is now you know on land and it's got
a lot of Christianity or kick
Christianity mixed into it but you can
tell as the movie continues that that
John David is making up some of these
rules as it goes along to fit the
situation yeah because I'm kind of
thinking that most of the pirates cannot
read that they can't read only a couple
of them could read yeah and you know the
captain being one of them but it's
pretty cool the the Pirates are pretty
vicious when they're doing their job but
when they're not doing their job they're
basically kind of bumbling idiots that
are having a good time they're like
drunken clam they're like drunken clown
so there's a bunch of weird [ __ ] that's
going on in the movie they're attacking
and killing people they're garroting
people they're doing all this horrible
stuff but they're actually quite funny
yeah when you when you see where they
come in when you see where these pirates
come from and what their mentality is
they're not taking any of this seriously
the show being a pirate yeah no that's
hot that's how pirates that's how they
do it I'll take you yeah kill them you
know this yeah whatever yeah it's just
like they generally do not give this
thing of it they don't get it do you
think it's like these things hilarious
yes yeah
and oh and I have to mention here this
one scene because this was one of my
favorite scenes at the [ __ ] movie
remember when they the Pirates go and
jump on this one boat and it's like a
big kind of big yacht there's like a
bunch of kind of yuppie ish people and
it turns out they were like smuggling
cocaine yeah cocaine was they they just
left it yeah cuz there but you know they
don't need that [ __ ] ever so they kill
most of the people on the boat and then
this one guy yes is hilarious it looks
like a [ __ ] you John Travolta yeah how
like a imagine a gay John John Travolta
in speedos with his shirt tied in a
little knot in penis yeah his chest and
he's like he's kind of funny he's kind
of bulky like I was muscular yeah kind
of dude and he decides that he's gonna
fight the Pirates food stuff and it's
absolutely not believe my eyes when you
came on I'm like this is wonderful
yeah and he does start whipping suck he
does start whipping ass on these pirates
he can't actually do that yeah and the
Pirates are watching him in single
combat whip these are these pirates
whose asses and the Pirates are just
loving it they're laughing their ass
backfires like why can't you shoot him
like no no no this is awesome yeah it's
funny because they even though even
though they're pirates in there cutting
idiots there's a lot of like warrior
virtue and warrior honor in it they just
want to see the fight happen and when
their own guys lose they just they
applauded it yeah yeah it's pretty cool
oh my god eventually eventually they get
him well yeah there's like there's like
oh yeah and then there was a woman and
what there was a woman on the crew a
young woman and they go we're gonna keep
her oh she's a good one and then later
on you know after they execute some of
the other crew they declare him guilty
of crimes I remember what crime it was
but well I read out like a like a
made-up did this same is it guilty yes
they're guilty
you know something well she breaks and
runs and they just shoot her and they
just laugh you know oh well you know
well fine well we'll find another woman
because here's the thing because the
Pirates are inbred and everything like
that you think that if they found like
young women on a ship that they would
want to keep them what they did but they
did but then they didn't what they were
just like I would she tried to get way
just [ __ ] shoot her yeah there's a
shot change your mind real quick yeah I
guess they figured like I said maybe
more be coming along also I think these
pirates were like not the brightest
bulbs no of course not they're inbred no
no I got that that doctor was actually
counseling them on the beginning that we
think his name is Don I think his name
is dr. Brazil yeah and that doctor from
the beginning who you thought was a nice
guy and he was the one that rented the
boat to Maynard of the Sun and was all
nice to him and [ __ ] well it turns out
that he knows about the Pirates and he
actually like counsels the Pirates he
tells them like where boats are gonna be
he told them they needed new blood that
they had to take in young kids and train
him as their own members they had to get
fresh women right because evidently
whoever founded this colony didn't have
enough women with him original yeah
they're starting to peter out yeah
because dr. Brazil if that is indeed his
character's name yeah we don't really
know because if you watch the movie
you'll see that the Pirates all talk
over each other they obviously don't
really prefer to each other by name now
and actually that kind of adds to this
movies charms it's hilarious if you slow
down and try to pick up what they're all
saying because some of the [ __ ] that
they're saying in the background is just
[ __ ] hilarious yeah but like yes oh
so this anthropologist he is an
anthropological interest in this colony
because they've been unchanged for so
long and went untouched by modern
civilization so he's trying to sustain
them I guess yeah well I and he doesn't
really care like if they kill people or
anything like that because he just
thinks it's so fascinating he tells me
to sustain their life for this long he
tells Blair Maynard that these are true
men that these are real men
yeah this is how men are actually
supposed to be living that they're not
supposed to be living in the modern and
the modern world bad and it's funny one
of the reasons why they can't Blair
Maynard alive is that they thought he
was a nobleman so yeah he had the same
last name and it's like somebody that
they were someone that they remember is
mentioned in their here's one of their
ancestors if thought he was a nobleman
and the idea of getting some noble
bloodlines back into their and into
their you know group would be a good
idea but they were making up a lot of
excuses to keep him alive now later of
dr. Brazil tells me he says oh you think
that they're really just keeping you
alive for your magic dick you know yeah
they basically like if they liked you
they would just keep you yeah because
the doctor was like they could have
killed me too when I stumbled across
this I loved it they didn't like you
they killed it
no we have to start getting into the
angle of what was happening to the son
yeah that's what I was just yes now this
is kind of like the whole theme of the
movie now Justin the bratty son he gets
to start torturing a member they start
torturing him with a note now here's an
interesting thing and I wanted to make
sure to forget this there is a scene in
this movie where he's kind of like he's
fastened to a pole by his neck by like a
rope or something like that and they put
like toothpicks or matchsticks or
something like that like like under his
eyes which are his owners yeah now this
movie came out in 1980 Dario Argento's
opera came out in 1987 now those of you
were Dario Argento fans will remember
the very iconic image I think it was
even on some of the posters of this
woman that had pins or needles like
taped under her eyes to keep her eyes
open and she's fast into a pole by a
rope because the killer wanted her to
watch like him killing people so I'm
kind of thinking that Dario Argento
maybe got that idea from this movie but
I'm not sure I'm not sure but it's very
similar so what they do and this is the
same thing that they did that the
Pirates did with the little girl that
you saw them kidnapping from the
beginning and she you know was a decoy
to bring Maynard and Justin into the
fold is they basically do they torture
them for several days that keep them
awake and then
you know they give them like propaganda
like they read out of the book and [ __ ]
like that
yeah and so they're brainwashing them
essentially the children the little girl
was brainwashed and now justin is being
brandished to be acquirement to be a
pirate actually to be the son of the
pirate chief yeah the captain yeah yeah
he wants another son figure because
David yeah he has a son figure it was
like a little but he's Portuguese are
Brazilian or something like that
yeah who they don't really say what he
was just John the captain John David
said that he was Portuguese [ __ ] yeah
that's Rico
once again Sam that's what he called him
so essentially he's implying well I
wanted a white kid yeah that would
that's later on that's a cool because I
have this one but he Portuguese in [ __ ]
I am taking this one now as my son you
know my manager he's me yes they are the
kid with the the first kids like pop and
they got him off of a boat earlier they
show how they got him he was just
working for an old guy who had a game
fishing big a fishing boat so it's
plausible he was a north and orphan yeah
so it was a huge advantage it was a huge
advantage for this kid to be in this
pirate cult basically is what it is but
the thing about Justin Maynard's
son Michael Caine's son is that he takes
to this pirate [ __ ] like that he's like
yeah I'm into this [ __ ] yeah they let me
shoot guns and let me kill people which
yes he even like shoots like a fruit out
of his dad's hands and all this other
kind of stuff and he says something to
his dad like I could have killed you
easily if I yeah like he just totally
yes so they start taking him out on rage
and everything a duck doctor Brazilian
we are assuming that the doctor dr.
Brazil that's mentioned is the doctor
we're talking about there was a pirate
that was also a doctor he may have been
dr. Brazil not sure exactly it's hard to
keep all these characters straight and
there really isn't much written about
this movie not a detail and like I said
I don't really think most of them are
not referred to by names yeah it's just
you and you and that woman and yeah
so anyway dr. Brazil goes to Blair while
he's still captive you know being used
as a breathing slave I guess he could
say yeah and says you know he said I
want my son back and all his kind of
stuff and he's like you should be proud
of your son your son would have never
been the man that he's gonna be because
you know they're gonna turn him into a
pirate he's gonna live as a real man
something you really couldn't give him
right which that all kind of comes into
play later is this kind of an underlying
kind of morality tale and that it's kind
of like professional guys need to have
adventures with their sons or they may
fall prey to more adventurous men and
they might end up falling into a life of
crime yeah
now that's this is kind of later on in
the movie they kinda go head to head
Blair Maynard and John David you know
who's the pirate captain and each one
Conda has to use warrior virtue to score
a victory you got the pirate using a
kind of a primitive warrior virtues and
then you have Blair Maynard using the
warrior virtues of a modern man as a
Korean War veteran
yeah and how it plays out in the very
end
yeah the modern man will win out and in
the end because of technology really
which you see this in the final scene
which I'm not sure about you just skip
so far ahead yeah it's not really that
far ahead
I'm okay but I mean baby in the final
scene spoiler alert
Blair Maynard okay the Pirates attack
they bite off more than they can chew
eventually what they do is they attack a
Coast Guard Cutter yeah the Coast Guard
come investigate yeah and this really is
a coast guard vessel yeah give credits
to this coast guard vessel at the end of
Lutie
and the Pirates board this Coast Guard
Cutter and it looked kind of like a
small bird it wasn't then Oliver Perry
class missile destroyer it was just some
kind of a fairly large patrol vessel you
now probably
large enough to maybe
hold a small helicopter I'm not have to
see it again
but anyway the Pirates board it they
wipe out the crew of the Coast Guard
crew maynard sneaks on there and tries
to rescue his son he gets into a big
head to head with the with the enemy
pirate captain and once he kills the
captain he goes back up on deck and he
looks down and he sees on the deck all
the Pirates with all the booty and their
that they've collected they're trying to
load it down on to their little skiff so
they can take him back to the island and
he realizes it right next to him under a
tarp is an m2 50 caliber machine gun big
hands like I know how to use those big
Bell 50 Cal you know these these rounds
are 50 Cal they're almost five inch long
rounds you know and he just unleashes on
the whole pirate group ya know with this
50 Cal they're just really cool
slow-motion shots of these guys just
being blown to pieces and yes like a
slasher basically kills them all now
there was some of the women and there
were a few of the pirates that didn't go
or probably evidently still back on the
island yeah cuz I don't think all of
them went on the raids but minoo did and
the little kids were still there and the
captives were still there but they just
the way they they kind of end the film
they let you know that the Coast Guard
is now aware that the Pirates came from
that Island that there were pirates so
you assume that the little kids were
rescued and that there was yeah showed
another Coast Guard boat coming after
but see like I said this was kind of
interesting and it kind of relates back
to what you were saying before because I
mean the whole underlying message of the
film I guess since Blair Maynard was he
wasn't a bad guy but he was just kind of
like an absent father yeah and you know
like you said he was more modern guy he
didn't like he wasn't mean to his kid
but he was just kind of like brushing
him off all the time just like yeah
whenever I just said yeah he was career
oriented yeah he was very careering not
family oriented so that what you were
saying before about you know when you
treat your kid like that it's very easy
for them to get sucked into something
else because like I said Justin
immediately he's like yeah I'm a [ __ ]
pirate now he takes the name to Barb
yeah and those you know if you don't
provide an inventive sense of adventure
songs they'll they might find that sense
of
venture is some kind of outlaw game
right exactly that's exactly yeah that's
exactly what happens but the interesting
thing is that at the very end when you
know the kid sees his dad like just
[ __ ] wiping out all the Pirates yeah
all of a sudden he appreciates his dad
well in not only that but then David
Warner's character yeah
he's willing to sacrifice his sacrifice
Justin yeah you know sir he doesn't get
killed
yeah so he sees oh well my dad would
never my real dad would never do it he
basically uses tue-barbe I guess that's
against new pirate name he uses him as a
hostage yeah against the father right
which you know that was like I said
Michael Caine's character would never
have known it like it was absent a
father as he wanted and the kid realizes
that yeah kid kind of snap back to
reality that this dude isn't my dad he's
not my dad and he's willing to kill me
rock just to save his own ass so you
know blood runs thick and you know right
a sticker the water yeah so that was
kind of the message of the movie but
like I said it's it's interesting to me
because I mean while that I guess the
tone of it maybe was kind of uneven and
people thought that German thought that
was jarring maybe I can't really
understand like why this didn't do as
well I mean obviously it's not going to
do as well as jaws because that was like
a [ __ ] great movie but this was the
early 80s you could not trust you could
not trust the movie industry at the time
you couldn't trust the you can trust the
critics of the 80s I mean look the thing
flopped true alright Escape from New
York flopped yeah a lot of really good
films flopped in those days and this one
I think it's better than jaws well I
don't know if I'd get out by their jobs
but I think it's better than I liked it
a lot better than the deep which did a
lot better hey you know what I mean
which was written by the same guy and
everything like that this was a this was
a high-quality flag they spent a lot of
money on it
those look 22 million dollars which was
a lot of money yeah the most
good-o all the aquatic shots looked good
the costumes looked good I thought the
acting was excellent my favorite [ __ ]
was when was during the pirate raids
like those guys moved and acted like
real pirates yeah they were doing stuff
on par with the Mad Max like a Mad Max
movie jumping from one thing to the next
time it up all the rigging and
everything that's why it was yeah it was
rad quite like yeah they were just like
rich they were like little monkeys like
final yeah very very very underrated
movie and this is one that if you've
never seen it you should go back and you
have to actually I think you can see it
on YouTube yeah it was thing was on his
template last I checked okay so you can
see yeah we got it on do we get it on
DVD or got it on DVD I think you've paid
$10 for yeah but it was worth it I want
it for my collection it's like I think
it's you know it's not available on
blu-ray now it's just you well it came
out Universal Studios like a few like in
2012 or something like that I guess they
released like a lot of kind of forgotten
movies from their serie Club the vault
series or something like that and this
was kind of part of that series where
they kind of clean we're cleaning out
their their health of like maybe zippy
this about this is a forgotten classic
and if you haven't seen it matter you
should really go out and check this this
movie actually yeah I really liked it
like much more than I was expecting it
stood the test of time it's a lot better
than I were even remembered it yeah and
they don't make movies like to say well
not really not really not yeah like I
said it also had kind of slasher
elements yeah yeah which I thought was
kind of interesting so it was kind of
similar to Jaws in that way yeah yeah
had a mixture of a lot of stuff in it
yeah because there was like elicited
really grisly it was like slasher with
history with historical documentary with
action movie
combined with comedy yeah some of the
[ __ ] the Pirates set was just [ __ ]
absolutely hilarious
and like I said the same that the guy in
the speedos was [ __ ] yeah that was
delightful and it's not you know they
don't play any hokey soundtrack or to
make it goofy or Jar Jar Binks aren't
kind of crap
it's just Pirates saying some funny [ __ ]
everybody while they were killing people
we're fighting you know which I kind of
think is probably what pirates were
really they looked realistic to that
back in the day I mean I don't know is a
lie by him but I I kind of got the vibe
that it's like yeah if I if I was alive
back then yeah that's exactly what
Pirates would be but well you know they
would you know board a ship and when the
fighting and break out they would cheer
in both sides shirred for their side and
the other side when they which is oh and
I forgot to mention too that like the
guy now was this the guy that got killed
by the John Travolta country guy and
remember they were throwing him
overboard
yeah they she's well here's the thing
like they seemed bummed out like when
one of their crew died like oh we lost
XY and Z yeah and they're like ah but
then like they're they had the guy and
they were gonna throw them of the dead
guy they're gonna throw him overboard
and then one of the Pirates like next to
him is just like looking at his shoes
and going and then he measures his own
foot he's like so casual yes I can't
really make a big deal about it yeah
there's like a drama don't throw them
overboard those boots yeah those are
good I can use those very practical is
yeah
yeah if you haven't seen it is a really
good if you you know if you like Michael
Caine and if you liked I like Michael
any of you lit yeah and we've got
another Michael Caine coming but we're
gonna keep that one on wraps okay yeah
well we'll do that one in a couple
there's several Michael Caine movies
that are worth mentioning yeah yeah but
this is one that like I said not a lot
of people seem to have seen it so if you
like jaws and the deep another kind of
Peter Benchley type of maritime stuff
and I feel like pirates you might want
to see it with slasher with yeah a
little bit of a slasher movie aesthetic
to it yeah yeah definitely one worth
checking out and that'll do it for our
latest movie review remember to go and
check us out on patreon go and check out
our blog and all that other stuff that I
usually say and we will see you next
time
yeah